in there forth and feisty estate
Democrats spent three hours in verbal
combat with one another and President
Donald Trump as a new frontrunner
senator Elizabeth Warren repeatedly took
hits from the other candidates and she
hit back first on her refusal to detail
how she would pay for government-funded
health care your signature senator is to
have a plan for everything except this
what most Americans want Medicare for
all who want it understand what that
really means it's Medicare for all who
can afford it
former Vice President Joe Biden struck
back against President Trump and his
rivals look my son did nothing wrong I
did nothing wrong
I'm the only one the stage has gotten
anything really big done and they
returned the favor
you got the disastrous war in Iraq done
you got a bankruptcy bill which is
hurting middle-class families all over
this country afterward each candidate
wore a game face senator you were
aggressive tonight how do you feel you
did um look people will make that
decision themselves that's what we're
sitting in the middle of Ohio Ohio a
state that Donald Trump won and he won
Pennsylvania and he won Michigan and he
won Wisconsin we need to build a blue
wall around those states win them and
make him pay for it senator Harris how
do you feel about the night I feel great
thank you
young people are not just registering
they're not just deciding that they're
gonna vote but on gun violence on
climate on immigration on healthcare on
any issue that matters they're leading
the way right now and we're gonna see
that reflected in the turnout at the
polls one worried that a combative
campaign could leave the Democratic
nominee damaged again is this campaign
getting uncivil no I'm not saying that
at all I'm just saying that after the
nightmare we saw last time around or for
a lot of reasons we went into that
general election weaker but one of them
has to have been the fact that there was
not enough unity within the Democratic
Party returning just two weeks after a
heart attack senator Bernie Sanders
joked at his own expense from here the
candidate field is likely to winnow down
the candidates who performed well here
are likely to see fundraising increase
those who didn't are likely to see it
decline the remaining candidates who
stay in the race will focus on the early
voting states Iowa New Hampshire South
Carolina and then in November one year
ahead of the 2020 election the
candidates who remain will get together
for the fifth democratic debate who has
really stood out Jena Bernie Sanders
Biden and Warner probably almost tied in
terms of their performance and then I
think Pamela Harris she's trying I don't
think she's gonna break out of that
fourth spot some who drop out during the
campaign will join the cabinet of the
winner so while some are running for
president some who won't succeed likely
already are running just to be part of
the team john Hendren al Jazeera
Westerville Ohio